[Music]
the recent increase in cova cases in
children is leading some parents to
bypass vaccine requirements so kids
younger than 12 can get the shot the fda
recently warned parents not to do this
but the agency may be getting closer to
authorizing the shot for younger kids
pfizer announced this week that its
cobit vaccine is safe and highly
effective in children ages 5 to 11 years
old cbs news chief medical correspondent
dr john lepuc spoke with one parent who
does not want to wait it was probably
the scariest thing as a parent i've had
to deal with lisa shapiro says she felt
helpless watching her daughter suffer
from covid is it going to turn on a dime
and is you know shortness of breath
walking up the stairs going to turn into
serious shortness of breath where she
can't catch her breath while both girls
are okay now shapiro knew she did not
want them to go through it again she got
her 14 year old daughter and payton
vaccinated this summer but her younger
daughter alexandra is only 11. we're
very itching to get it we're impatiently
waiting have you been tempted to ask
your pediatrician
come on she's 11 and a half that's
almost 12. i have been absolutely
tempted i know of some families who have
very large 11 year olds who have sort of
snuck into some of the mass vaccine
sites and things like that dr scott
krugman is vice chair of pediatrics at
the hermann and walter samuelson
children's hospital at sinai in
baltimore
when a parent asks you to vaccinate
their kid who's under 12
what do you say to them it's really
important to wait for the tests to be
done the studies to be done in the
advisory council on immunization
practices and the american kind of
pediatrics to say now's the time and
we're hoping now as the time is coming
sooner rather than later parents are
also hoping authorization comes soon
especially since pfizer said its vaccine
is safe and effective in young children
what do you think about the news coming
out of pfizer about their vaccine for
five to 11 year olds
i'm thrilled i'm excited i've been
waiting for it and hoping for it having
the vaccine is everything it will take
so much worry
away
dr john lepuc is joining us right now
good morning good morning now um should
the authorization process make parents a
little bit more optimistic i think it
should you know nate the fda can't win
right some people say they're moving too
quickly other people saying they're
moving too slowly remember five days ago
there was an advisory meeting of the fda
uh to consider whether the booster
should be given the pfizer booster
should be given for people 16 and over
and you remember the president got a
little bit ahead of this and had raised
expectations that on the 20th of
september that people 16 and above would
would be eligible so when it didn't
happen people were frustrated right i
mean but he did say it has to be
a cdc and fda approved and sure enough
during the advising i sat through eight
hours of them discussing really smart
people and they said you know what
the data's not there yet we're going to
say it's okay for a different group but
we'll see we may change our
recommendation as more information
becomes i think people should find that
reassuring their checks and balances
what are the dangerous potential dangers
i mean what's the big deal basically if
you give a kid 11 year old say an adult
dose of the vaccine well we're always
taught in medical school that kids are
not just little grown-ups so
it's there are changes in hormones kids
are going through puberty uh and they're
very careful about the kind of doses
they give you too much you could get too
much of an inflammatory response you
could get pain at the site fever
headaches joint pains even some rare
inflammatory reactions i spoke to pfizer
yesterday and i talked about the dose
remember 30 micrograms of the physio
dose vaccines given in adults they tried
the 10 20 and 30. they found you know
what 10 the lower dose gave just a
really good response so you always
medicine want to give the lowest amount
of a medicine that still gets the
response well you said you mentioned
that you talked to pfizer yesterday
because now they're saying it's okay for
kids 5 to 11. how soon can we get it
then well it's another example of the
regulatory process that should reassure
people so even though pfizer just came
out this week and said it's safe and
effective the fda says fine we want to
see the data and we think that they're
going to get that visor tells me they're
going to get that to the fda by the end
of this month and then they're going to
not believe what pfizer said they're
going to go through their records and
they're going to do their own statistics
it may take about another month so i'm
hearing maybe around halloween does the
spike in covet cases and children dispel
the narrative that kids they can't get
it yeah
absolutely kids can get it about one in
four of the new cases are in kids you
know we see 28 million kids in this new
age group uh five to 11 so there's a
real opportunity to vaccinate this group
uh we're seeing a a rise in
hospitalization we've done a lot of
stories about that for so long we were
told you don't really have to worry
about kids and parents still lean on
that yeah they do i think that's a false
narrative the general idea is that the
kids are then tend to get less severe
illness but they can still get really
sick and die and remember now as more
and more grown-ups get vaccinated then
it's going to tend to gravitate down to
lower groups that are not vaccinated so
what's your advice on how you can keep
your children safe until they get the
vaccine all right so it's multiple
layers of protection okay so everybody's
got to get vaccinated who can possibly
get vaccine thinking about a school
right everybody should be wearing a mask
who can wear a mask
testing not enough testing's being done
dr rochelle wolensky is the head of the
cdc
was talking with me a couple of weeks
ago and said you know there are billions
of dollars that have been allocated for
testing for schools but the schools
aren't asking for it and finally and
super important is ventilation and
filtration we've been talking about this
trying to hammer this the aerosol
scientists are jumping up and down
saying it's really important it travels
through the air think about cigarette
smoke it's not just six feet or three
feet if you were smoking a cigarette and
we're indoors and it's not well
ventilated am i going to smell it yeah
then potentially you can do that so
merv 13 filters hepa filters open the
doors crack the windows but i think
parents out there should talk to their
school boards and the local authorities
and say what are you doing what's the
plan for ventilation infiltration if the
school isn't testing parents you can
test yourself as well yeah thank you so
much john we appreciate